حذر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اف جرنت حزب
الله من التصعيد على طول الحدود الشماليه
قائلا انما فعلناه في غزه يمكن ان نفعله
ايضا في بيروت وبعد اجتماع في مقر القياده
الشماليه قال جارنت ان الجيش الاسرائيليه
يضرب حزب الله بقوه واضاف ان نحو
250 من مقاتلي الحزب
استهدفوا لن نسم بالعوده الىو الذي كنا
فيه حتى السادس من اكتوبر اننا نضرب حزب
الله بقوه لديهم نحو 150 قتيلا ولديهم
العديد من الممتلكات المتضرره وقد دفعوا
بعيدا عن خط السياج في المنطقه والقوات
الجويه تحلق بحريه فوق لبنان وسنزيد كل
هذه الجهود هناك شيء واحد واضح من اجل
اعاده السكان مطلوب احد امرين اما اجراء
نحن مهتمون به وفي اطاره سينشا وضع مختلف
او سنحقق واقعا مختلفا نتيجه للنشاط
العسكري حزب الله ينظر الى ما يحدث في غزه
ويفهم جيدا ان ما فعلناه في غزه يمكن ان
نفعله ايضا في
بيروت